back here in New York the largest United
Nations General Assembly in recent years
will convene in person right here after
nearly two years of virtual meetings our
correspondent Pam lafalk has been
closely following the United Nations for
decades I get a lot of emails from you
over the course of a year this is a
challenging time for the globe to put it
mildly right you've got War you've got
exceedingly troubling Economic Times in
many places and then you've got the
major scheduling conflict called the
Queen's funeral funeral exactly so what
can we expect when this opens tomorrow
well good morning both of you the U.N
week is the world the world series of
diplomacy
193 Nations we can expect it is as you
mentioned Tony the oh the most heads of
state ever and they will gather for the
77 starter session tomorrow now the
opening of this year's session comes as
you mentioned is the world uh is is
involved in and the Ukraine war rages uh
the uh the gains
um Grant Ukraine is gaining ground
um and uh no question there is a lot of
concern about what Russia might do
there's also heightened concern about
climate change as the world continues to
see we see so even this morning
unprecedented flooding and fires 13 U.S
presidents have used their speeches to
Define America's place in the world as
President Biden is expected to do when
he speaks on Wednesday he's expected to
focus on avoiding World War and Global
hunger but also there is potentially a
global economic downturn so it's a
daunting agenda Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski will will beam in
remotely despite Russia's objections
zelenski his wife the first lady of
Ukraine is expected to make an in-person
appearance at the session at un
headquarters and remember the U.N
brokered brain deal between Ukraine and
Russia was negotiated in July and it may
be one would hope a stepping stone to
brokering the peace one day
as former U.N Chief Doug hamerschel said
it best the United Nations was not
created to bring us to heaven but in
order to save us from hell and that's
the theme this year yeah and a busy busy
week for uh Ukraine Ukraine's first lady
who's now at the women's funeral is
going to be back in New York Pamela
thank you very much